[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme j'étais une petite fille avec mon
frère je jouer au lego
je passais des heures avec mon frère a
assemblé méticuleusement toutes ces
petites caisses pour créer dé mon
meilleur des châteaux des navettes
spatiales extraordinaire on m'a semblé
sa une à une toutes ces petites pièces
et puis on jouait à la gare à la guerre
et un seul qu on détruisait tout en
quelques secondes
évidemment j'étais toujours un petit peu
triste de retrouver mon beau château en
mille morceaux
mais finalement ça ne durait jamais
vraiment très longtemps parce que
directement je recommençais à imaginer
un monde encore meilleur un château
encore plus beau une navette spatiale
encore plus extraordinaire rien n'est
immuable
l'architecturé est toujours en mouvement
c'est probablement ces heures passées à
assembler des petites pièces de lego et
le soutien inconditionnel de ma maman
qui m'ont permis de devenir architecte
et j'ai eu la chance de trouver un
bureau d'architecturé où j'ai pu
continuer à jouer au lego avec mes
collègues dans ce bureau particulier il
n'était pas seulement question
d'architecturé mais aussi d'énergie de
bâtiments à basse consommation de
bâtiments passifs de bâtiments où il n'y
a pas besoin de radiateur c'est là que
j'ai compris que je ne savais rien sur
le matériau le plus important de la
construction
d'ailleurs d'après
quel est le matériau le plus important
dans la construction
je vous donne des indices son poids est
d'environ 1,2 kg par mètre cube
certains pensent peut-être au bois il
peut constituer jusqu'à 99 % du volume
d'un bâtiment et il est gratuit
pour le moment je les ai entendus parmi
vous certains m'ont déjà dit il s'agisse
de l'air en effet si vous imaginez le
bâtiment dans lequel nous nous trouvons
actuellement la majorité de ce bâtiment
est constitué d'air nous ne vivons pas
dans les murs nous vivons dans l'ère
qu'il renferme
imaginez cette même conférence ici qui
est dehors sous la pluie
ce ne serait pas pareil l'air un certain
poids 1,2 kg par mètre cube l'air à une
certaine température qu'on n'espère pas
trop chaude pas trop froide l'air à une
certaine vitesse l'air un certain degré
d'humidité l'air à une certaine
pollution l'air à une certaine odeur
je viens de sculpter un arc d'air mais
si l'air est le matériau le plus
important de l'architecturé si nous
essayons de maintenir grâce à nos
bâtiments
une situation confortable pour abriter
des activités humaines
comment faire pour représenter leur il
faut ajouter une quatrième dimension à
la hauteur largeur et profondeur aux
trois dimensions de l'espace pour
pouvoir représenter l'air en mouvement
le temps l'air est constamment en
mouvement
l' architecture est toujours en
transformation si je vous demande
maintenant de représenter une ligne du
temps ici en occident la plupart d'entre
vous représentez une ligne avec une
flèche
si on applique ça un bâtiment ce serait
considérer la vie d'un bâtiment depuis
sa naissance sa conception sa vie son
utilisation jusqu'à sa mort sa
destruction
j'étais surprise de contact de constater
au bureau un jour qu'un projet de
rénovation est arrivé dans bâtiment des
années 80 ce bâtiment était un peu plus
jeune que moi est déjà obsolète
donc ce que nous avons prévu pour cette
rénovation
c'était des tirs est au maximum la ligne
du temps de ce bâtiment donc de lui
enfiler un pull d'isolant de faire de
plus grandes fenêtres d'améliorer le
confort de vie et de le transformer
finalement en un bâtiment résidentiel
alors considérer le temps comme une
ligne comme une flèche
c'est bien mais ça mène de toute manière
à l'affaiblissement du système
parce que si on extrait des ressources
on les consomme et puis on les rejette
comme des déchets ou de la pollution
au bout d'un moment ça ne peut pas
continuer pourquoi ne pas passer d'un
mode de conception du temps linéaire
vers un mode de conception circulaire
envisagé le temps dans un dans une
conception circulaire c'est un peu ce
que j'appelle la philosophie du petit
coin veuillez laisser s'il vous plaît
cet endroit tel que vous auriez aimé le
retrouver en diminuant les ressources
utilisées par les bâtiments les
consommations d'énergie d'eau etc
ça permet de penser à un bâtiment non
pas à travers un temps une ligne mais à
travers différents cycles le cycle
annuel des saisons le cycle du jour de
la nuit le cycle des matériaux le cycle
de l'eau le cycle de l'énergie nous
avons au sein du bureau aussi réaliser
un projet il s'agit d'un petit module
qui est autonome en énergie autonome en
eau et même indépendant des réseaux de
distribution
donc ça signifie que ce petit module
peut être transportés d'un lieu à un
autre assemblée des assemblées un peu à
l'image de lego et qu'il à 0 empreinte
sur l'environnement
alors ne pas avoir d'en prendre sur
l'environnement c'est déjà quelque chose
qui est assez positif mais il est déjà
trop tard
on ne peut pas se contenter de faire
juste des bâtiments qui n'ont pas
d'empreintes sur l'environnement il faut
aller plus loin il faut aller au delà il
faut des bâtiments il faut des
constructions une conception qui nous
permettent d'évoluer d'améliorer
l'environnement dans lequel on se trouve
d'une conception circulaire pourquoi ne
pas passer à une conception
d'amélioration perpétuelle de nos
constructions au sein du bureau
nous avons développé le concept de perm
à city qui s'inspire de la permaculture
l'idée est de créer un morceau de ville
un peu comme un morceau de forêt plus il
grandit plus il se développe plus
utilisable il apporte des nutriments et
dépollue l'atmosphère le concours
réinventer la métropole de paris a été
l'occasion de tester ce concept de perm
à city à l'échelle d'un quartier
donc nous avons mis ensemble les
différents faire les différentes
fonctions créer un quartier comme un
morceau de forêt et donc dans ce
quartier c'est l'être humain qui a
remplacé la voiture au centre des
espaces publics et par exemple aussi
plutôt que d'avoir des parkings enterrés
et que faire si un jour la voiture
venait à disparaître nous avons prévu
des parkings or seuls donc un jour si
jamais il ya plus de voiture il ya plus
besoin de battures on peut faire des
ouvertures et avoir des lieux qu'ils
puissent être baigné de lumière
naturelle pour réaliser un projet qui a
un impact positif sur l'environnement
nous avons fait le bilan carbone c'est à
dire analyser toutes les émissions
créées par ce quartier que ce soit
l'énergie grise et matériaux l'énergie
d'utilisation
ou encore tout ce qui peut se passer au
niveau de la mobilité le premier point a
été de réduire ses émissions et puis
après de les compenser avec des espaces
verts avec de l'énergie renouvelable
avec des peintures photocatalytiques
finalement nous sommes arrivés non pas
juste à compenser les émissions du
quartier mais carrément à absorber plus
de carbone qu'il n'en était émis pour
vous donner une image voici une carte de
paris
la petite tache rouge représente ce
projet de perm à city nous avons calculé
que cette toute petite tache rouge
absorbe autant de co2 que la totalité
des espaces verts de paris
finalement métaphoriquement c'est ceci
que nous avons fait comme projet alors
pourquoi est ce que je vous raconte tout
ça aujourd'hui
voilà j'ai trois bonnes nouvelles à vous
annoncer
la première bonne nouvelle c'est que ce
type de projet basse énergie passive ou
même neutre n'est pas nécessairement
plus cher que les projets comme on les a
toujours fait
la deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est que le
plus gros efforts à fournir
c'est justement transformer cette
mentalité que nous avons d'imaginer que
le temps n'est pas une flèche linéaire
mais pourquoi pas circulaire pourquoi
pas en amélioration perpétuelle enfin la
troisième bonne nouvelle c'est que nous
disposons actuellement de toutes les
techniques les technologies les
matériaux la conception nécessaire à
créer ses meilleurs monde de demain
alors la question que je me pose que je
vous pose c'est pourquoi ne pas
commencer dès aujourd'hui
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]